So I know we're talking about an
ideology Raymond that is incredibly
powerful and it's heavily incentivized
people to go and be warlike and also to
be fearless because you know that if you
die you're going to you know you're
going to get all the ladies should we
just say. So it's you know it's a good
deal and personally if I was around then
I might well have signed up. However,
they there must have been something else
to these to to these warriors because to
take on the Romans, to take on all these
ancient civilizations, the Persians,
they must have been incredibly well
drilled as armies and ferocious fighters
and also highly trained.
>> Okay, so yeah, like I said, this is
known as one of the big history big
mysteries of history, the Arab conquest.
They're not easy to um explain. Um okay
some of the theories there was this
massive desecation of Arabia they claim
where it was really becoming barren and
so this caused a massive migration that
we don't really know about of who who
knows the number of Arabs with their
women and children and camels just
inundating regions. That's one theory.
The other theory which I already
mentioned the mo most prominent one
which is that the Persians and the
Romans were so exhausted from constant
warfare. Uh but you [clears throat]
can't really say that these guys were
well militarily trained. They actually
weren't. And when you and we know their
weapons, their weapons are whatever they
could plunder from their slain victims,
you know. Okay, I mean that was it. Um
so and they didn't really we don't know
of any kind of Arab uh military, you
know, formations. It was just it was the
Bedawin raid where, you know, which
continues in fact with a lot of
historically the Islamic nomadic
peoples, Turks and Mongols and Arabs,
they they were great horsemen, that's
for sure. So I mean they definitely had
that they had lightning speed. The
battle of Yarmmuk, for example, we know
that one of the reasons that they won is
because they were used to desert
fighting and apparently there was a
desert storm which the Romans couldn't
handle and it blinded them whereas the
Arabs were used to those conditions. Um,
but one of the things that I always
found interesting is there's a
relatively obscure but early um
chronicle that it's from Spain and it's
uh in the 8th century. So, it talks
about uh the 700s. It talks, it's very
early and it talks about the Arab
conquest and it makes this kind of
curious remark about how they did not
win through manliness but through
stealth and deception. Okay, which you
know I mean I don't know how to
interpret that. Uh but basically the
idea is they they weren't they they
wouldn't fight head-on in a kind of you
know in a sort of chivalick which didn't
even exist at that point necessarily
kind of way or like blunt force. It was
just hit and run tactics kind of
deception which definitely marks the
later way of war of like I said the
Turks and the Ottomans and the Seljixs
and these groups. So that's another you
know thing I'm throwing out there
because I I don't hear people talk about
it but it is in in the chronicles. The
the the official Christian explanation
was God had done this to punish us for
our sins. He had raised Amalcch to come
and punish us. Yeah
>> because we deserved it.
>> Now that must
>> for crossdressing purposes. I'm not even
kidding. [laughter] There's an there's
an early document that talks and it says
and it says I have it quoted in my in my
book sword and scimitar I'm forgetting
right now um pseudo methodius I think uh
but it says something like he he he
raised them up to punish us and because
and it it lists all kinds of numbers of
immoralities and one of them is because
men were dressed like women
>> there you go [laughter] well so God is
anti-trans gon's a trans f
>> anyway but that must have sent real
shock waves through the Christian world
to see this new religion, these new
armies fight in this new style almost
guerrilla warfare style and just cut
through swaves of Christian heartland.
And that's see that's the missing piece
of the puzzle and nobody you know
invariably when we talk about Islam
Muslim Christian hostilities from a
historical point of view
>> it starts with the crusades everyone
starts with the crusades and nobody
seems to understand what was building up
towards the crusade in which included a
lot of fear and terror because um you
know Bernard Lewis has a great quote
which I quote from him and he talks
about how you know by the time it was
you know after these Arab conquests and
now let's say it's the 8th and 9th
century the Europeans ans were just
traumatized and devastated and a lot of
what we called or used to call it's not
a very uh favorable term anymore but the
dark ages was in large measure because
of these Arab conquests okay and uh
Henry Perne for example he was a
historian 19th century that was his
thesis which which is that the dark ages
was a byproduct of these Muslim
conquests which took what was once a
Roman Christian lake at the time right
Egypt had commerce with Spain and with
Rome and Syria you know it was one all
it was Christendom
>> and by by you know chopping that in half
and essentially appropriating and
seizing the older richer more
sophisticated more educated region which
was the Middle East and the near east
that's one of the main reasons that
Europe entered into this perilous dark
age and Henry Pin also you know he I
think the title of his book or the his
argument is or his famous line is that
without Muhammad there's no Charlemagne
okay so the one necessarily led to the
rise of the other and that entire system
and you know so Most people don't know
what built up and what was coming, you
know, in the centuries before the first
crusade. They just assume there's these,
you know, these powerful land grabbing
hungry, greedy knights want to go and
just I I've I've quoted this quote. I'm
going to quote it for you guys so many
times. I think I've memorized it, but it
just it shows you the rot of academia
and uh it really underscores what I'm
trying to tell you. And it's by John
Espazito.
This is a professor at Georgetown
University. I don't know if he's still
there. He's probably very old uh right
now, but he was there when I was there.
I I went to Georgetown University for a
time in Washington DC and um and it it's
a bastion of kind of Islamic studies and
whatnot, but I didn't know this at the
time, but it it was a very kind of
compromised bastion.
>> Mhm.
>> Anyway, one of his books which is uh
it's it's called Islam the straight
path. And keep in mind this guy, he was
this is in the early 2000s, let's say.
He was very very active and his book
came out and he's the editor of the
Oxford um history of Islam, for example.
He was the guy that the, you know, the
the FBI and the CIA intelligence
analysts, they talked to him to
understand about Islam and whatever. He
has this line in his book, Islam the
Straight Path, which verbatim, I might
be getting a little off, but he says,
"Five centuries of peaceful coexistence
elapsed between Christians and Muslims
before an imperial papal power play led
to a series of so-called holy wars that
have left an enduring legacy of mistrust
from Muslims to Christians."
So what he's saying is before the first
crusade which starts in 1095 everything
before that from moment from Muhammad's
life until all the stuff I'm telling you
was peaceful coexistence.
Okay that that's the official narrative.
So that's why I think it's very
important to really highlight what you
just mentioned which is this really this
was a traumatizing event the sundering
you know the first breakup of
Christendom with most of it being
conquered by this hostile faith and the
rest of it being bombarded in the 8th
century all these islands were con the
Mediterranean islands were constantly
being attacked and conquered slave raids
were constantly a given thing the whole
idea so much of what we know as
feudalism and had to do with all these
the coasts of the southern coast of
Europe. So many people actually
abandoned them because they were the
site of raids, slave raids coming from
the Islamic world now, North Africa. And
they would habitually go and enslave
Europeans and take them back. And and
the emporium for white flesh was Cordoba
in Spain, which was conquered, like I
said, uh starting in 7-Eleven. And
that's where they would that was where
they would sell white flesh which always
you know fetched the high price amongst
the Muslims.